saints row is a series that is bursting
with secrets developer volition has
hidden little details and easter eggs
throughout each of the mainline titles
in this bombastic selection of games to
entice the player into the great unknown
or more likely just some dungeon some of
these are in-game some are tidbits
surrounding the greater development of
the series itself but these are 10
things you didn't know about saints row
number 10
chuck nick's books throughout the city
of stillwater in the first saints row
you will come across buildings labeled
chuck nicks books this is a reference to
chuck palahniuk the writer of the
invention of sound and most famously
fight club and always remember the first
rule of fight club is to have fun and be
yourself
number nine
the merman
in saints row two if you head to the
eastern side of the hotels and marina
district scrawled on a billboard is the
warning beware the merman along with a
small note describing the creature as
flippered and dangerous
the note also explains that the being
has been sighted off the shores of the
marina a random npc even references the
creature saying legend has it there's a
half man half fish who lives down here
although the painted monster depicts a
half-man half-shark-like hybrid the real
merman turns out to be brian murman a
member of the saints row 2 art team
number eight missing ships in saints row
the third if you enter any of the cargo
ships in game you'll find a list of
missing ships these range from real-life
disappearances to fictional ships the
developers love the list goes as follows
the bachemo this is a reference to the
uss bachmo a real-life ghost ship that
supposedly was abandoned off the coast
of alaska in 1931. it was cited multiple
times for decades after its abandonment
with its last sighting in 1969 hms
seahorse i couldn't find any information
on ships named the hms seahorse that
were lost at sea further adding to the
mystery of its addition to this list the
axiom this is the fictional spacecraft
that the entire population of earth
lives on in the disney pixar film wally
the usg ishimura another fictional
spacecraft this time the zombie alien
infested spaceship from the dead space
series of games the octavius this is a
real-life legendary ship found off the
coast of greenland in which the entire
crew froze to death and were perfectly
preserved as the story goes the captain
was frozen stiff at his desk with a
quill in hand writing his captain's log
the borealis this is the fictional but
pivotal resistance vessel in the
half-life series appearing in both
episodes of half-life 2 as well as an
eluded cameo in portal 2 the heart of
gold
this is the fictional spacecraft from
the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
series the mary's celeste a real-life
ship that was completely abandoned with
no trace of the crew it was later
immortalized by many retellings
including a famous fictional retelling
by sir arthur conan doyle the uss snook
this is a real-life u.s navy submarine
that was lost without a trace near the
philippines in 1945.
number seven the red faction series
there's a lot of cross-referencing and
potential universe combining between the
saints row series and red faction series
volition developer of both series has
denied any connection between the two
just some heartfelt homages and winks
towards each other the most major
connective tissue between the two games
is the altor corporation throughout
saints row and saints row 2 the altor
corporation rose from a smaller company
that sponsored sports teams in saints
row to a mega corporation and main
antagonist in saints row 2. they
seemingly continued their evil doings
from earth to mars where they were the
main antagonist in the first red faction
game smaller but fun tidbits that pull
the worlds together are red planet red
passion and red fiction used books in
saints row 2 a radio ad advertises the
tv show red planet red passion a drama
about a mining colony on mars two of the
characters in the show are parker and
eos both characters featured in red
faction red fiction used books is a used
bookstore in the summerset district in
saints row in saints row 2 that shares
the same logo and naming convention as
red faction one of the last major
connections between the two series comes
in the gangstas in space mission in
saints row the third in the final cut
scene your character will start to
recite a speech and then forget his line
this speech is word for word the same as
the one main character alec mason gives
at the end of red faction gorilla to
further the link if you chose the male 1
voice when creating your character the
lines will be said by voice actor troy
baker
voice of alex mason
and some other stuff
nothing big
[Music]
number six pc project red before
becoming the powerhouse behind the
witcher series cd project red just known
as cd project in 2009 was tasked by thq
to make a port of saints row 2 for the
pc according to numerous reports the
port was a buggy mess on release and due
to thq auctioning off all of its assets
after going bankrupt in 2013 the source
code of the pc version was thought to be
completely lost after years of being
almost unplayable in 2019 volitions
stated that they had found the source
code and began patching the game with
steam and mod support
number five the 31 theory before i begin
this theory i want to talk about the
trope of arc numbers have you ever been
watching or reading something and a
certain number comes up again and again
that makes you go
these
are arc numbers
arc numbers are numbers in a fictional
work that pop up again and again with no
contextual connection in saints row the
magic number is 31 or it's inverse 13.
and this is not a theory i've made up in
my mind like some over-caffeinated
theorists in saints row the third during
a homie conversation kinsey relates the
thirty-one theory the thirty-one theory
anything important is always connected
to a thirty-one nightblade season three
best season aired in january had 13
episodes
season 3 aired on the first month of the
year 13 episodes
31-13
and although this theory is stated for
the first time in the third game in the
series the 31 chambers have appeared in
every game the list is long and i'm not
going to read all of the references
but i'll read some as fast as possible
saints row the king penthouse code is
3131 there are 31 discrete items in the
funky fresh pack there are 31
single-player achievements and 31 wins
to achieve the true skill rank for
kingpin saints row 2. there's a mission
called assaults on precinct 31 which is
also a reference to the movie assault on
precinct 13. gap mentions his jail time
was 2 years and 31 days the news channel
in game is news 13 stillwater one hitman
mission has you tracking down an
arsonist that has burned down 31
buildings there are 31 taunts and
compliments for your gang saints row the
third one level is called 31 days later
referencing 28 days later murder brawl
31 occurs during the course of the game
the clapper at the end of the gangstas
and space mission says that you are on
take 31 and on a saints row website
profile in real life johnny gatt's
birthday is labeled as 1980 with his
death in 2011 making him you guessed it
31 saints row 4. a new code 1331 comes
up in the mission platforming rift
kinsey who created this theory in game
states that her planetary defense budget
is 3.1 million dollars zinyak refers to
you as special prisoner 31 and when
choosing a character from the
customization presets choosing option 6
mentions the 31st amendment so there you
go
volition loves that good old lucky
thirty one
[Music]
number four saints row two secret areas
as stated at the beginning of this video
saints row is a series that is bursting
with secrets
this is no more apparent than in saints
row two
saints row 2 has 32 secret areas
and these aren't just randomly placed
throughout the map these are labeled
in-game as explorations and although
they don't give you any reward for
finding all of them they're still
technically part of the completion
process
the list is long and i'm not gonna label
all of them because i've already done
that too much this video but some
standouts are the developer offices uh
recreation of the parthenon in amber
brook and the super secret area complete
with super secret sea creature
[Music]
number three secret stash the most video
gamey of all the secrets on this list
has to be the secret stash from the
first saints row
similar to the konami code this secret
grants your character super human
abilities namely human torch style fire
and superhuman strength
the way to get it is equally as cryptic
as a castlevania ii guide number one
equip the pimp cane weapon which can
only be acquired by using the pimp cane
cheat number two after midnight start a
theft in the sloppy seconds in the
saints row district number three enter
the code to the safe backwards but be
careful because the joystick cannot
return to the center position or else
the easter egg won't work number 4 exit
the safe tracking menu by pressing down
on the d-pad twice and number 5 exit the
sloppy seconds through any of the doors
and the easter egg unlock screen should
trigger important to note that the
secret stash will still remain even if
you're killed but if you try to save or
load a game it'll disappear
number 2 skydivers in saints row 2 you
may see random civilians falling out of
the sky and no this isn't an elden ring
sky wolves reference the in-universe
explanation for this is that the
civilians skydiving all have failed
parachutes if you are standing by the
open grave in the morning wood cemetery
at the right place and right time a body
will flop from the sky and land directly
in the middle of
it number one
mathematical in saints row the third if
you head to a selection of cranes
throughout steelport you can find an
ornate sword sticking out of a box
leaning up against the base these swords
are modeled after finn sword in
adventure time and not just the regular
sword he wields but specifically the
sword that flies through the sky during
the title card
with each game saints row has ramped up
the zaniness and ludicrousness of their
worlds especially in their easter eggs
and secrets i love how they capture the
zeitgeist and cultural references of the
eras that they're made in as well as
create lore and conspiracy theories
within the games themselves with the
next saints road just around the corner
let me know what your favorite secrets
are in the comments and for everything
video games catch you next time here at
gamespot